I think tone is important in the
independent movement you have a lot of
people who are just angry and they're
always going to be angry and they're
going to beat up on the on the parties I
don't know that that helps us a lot
because the reality is
candidates today and incumbents are
responding to the incentive structure
that lets them keep their job and we all
do that in every Walk of Life if if
you're a street sweeper or a doctor you
do the things that let you keep your job
and get ahead and so we can beat up
incumbent Republicans and democrats for
their behavior but it's not going to
change anything because they're acting
rationally within the system if we can
change the system we will change their
behavior and that's where the
independent space is contributing so
much to the politics of the country
foreign
[Music]
it is my pleasure and privilege to
welcome to forward one of the biggest
leaders for independent politics in the
country you might know him from NBC and
MSNBC where he's an analyst former
member of Congress out of the state of
Florida David Jolly welcome David Andrew
it's great to finally be with you on
your podcast congrats on this by the way
oh thanks brother so you and I got to
know each other when you were hitting
something called the serve America
movement that merged with forward over
the summer what the heck was Sam
uh it was one of those groups and this
Restless independent space that you
found yourself in coming out of 2016.
now I was just leaving Congress I was
still a registered Republican but a
group of call them disaffected voters
um equally really Republicans and
Democrats coming out of the 2016
election said they wanted to do
something different they wanted to shake
things up they wanted to create more
choice in American politics and so they
launched the serve America movement not
really sure they would admit what they
were about to take on about to do they
found themselves on a bit of a journey
they ran Unity tickets for governor and
lieutenant governor in the state of New
York in the state of Connecticut meaning
a Republican and a Democrat on the same
ticket they kind of set out to be a
Centrist party they did well enough to
get ballot access in future elections to
get some party recognition but what they
discovered along the way was one
creating a new political Coalition is
really hard and and the fundamental
thing they discover covered is if you
start out by saying hey we want
everybody to believe what we believe you
immediately set a ceiling and so I
joined them I guess about the time they
were undergoing that discovery that they
had hit a ceiling trying to be a
Centrist party and they asked me to help
lead the organization to the next stage
and the next stage was a few years
redefining our value proposition as a
big tent and then ultimately leading me
to you and forward to join the forward
Coalition and and the newly merged party
that you have well David you have a
deeply personal Journey yourself where I
think it's fair to call you one of the
non-trump fans in the Republican party
and you wound up running a foul a party
Orthodoxy though you often say it's a
bit deeper than that uh that that even
when you were Republican you weren't
necessarily a good Republican
yeah look I I was never a good enough
Republican I call myself kind of a Bush
41 Republican and truly I use that
reference because as I was coming of age
Bush 41 was breaking up with the NRA
which actually was a pretty significant
inflection point
as Gingrich brought in the Gingrich
Revolution I was you know a pretty tried
and true conservative at least in theory
I believe in certain conservative
economic theories but we clearly clearly
saw the cultural revolution within the
Republican party and then you saw the
outsized influence of a number of
special interest groups including the
NRA which led to the Bush 41 moment look
Bush 43 we were a time at War he was
doing things that I generally agreed
with but then as Bush 43 wasn't
conservative enough for a lot of
Republicans in the emergence of the Tea
Party happened that's where I really
started my long breakup if you will
um I I was my lifetime Hill staffer in
and out of Congress and in virtually
every capacity so I had a front row seat
at a lot of the evolution I did not
anticipate in 13 running and ultimately
being elected to congress and I
immediately was not a good enough
Republican the day I arrived the joke
Andrew this is interesting it was this
nationally watched special election not
because of the candidates but because it
was a 50 50 District Obama had won it
twice a republican member of Congress
had it and and passed away in office my
predecessor did so both major parties
and all the special interest groups came
in about 25 million dollars in about 10
or 12 weeks and so they defined Jolly as
an NRA pro-life down the line chamber uh
anti-union right to work all of those
special interest groups who thought they
were helping me spent money on my behalf
ultimately I got elected and the moment
I started voting they had whiplash
they're like wait who's who's this guy
and the nrcc said wait what are you
doing you're not with us in lockstep on
every step of the every vote so even
before Trump
on issues like marriage equality climate
science gun control campaign Finance
reform immigration reform I was one of
those thorns in the side of the party
saying look we're going in the wrong
direction and we can actually win by
going in this other direction by
actually giving voice to more people and
then the the bomb of Donald Trump
arrived on the scene and that was it for
me I I say this not asking for credit
but as a as a time stamp in December of
15 on the house floor
for a couple years I became the only
Republican to speak out against Donald
Trump on the house floor and to say no
way we're not doing this and it was
after he called for the Muslim ban but
then when others came around you know
Paul Ryan and I actually on exactly the
same day that following summer said I'm
not there yet when he got the nomination
Paul Ryan found a way to get there I
never did and ultimately left the party
shortly thereafter yeah so you you've
joked with me in other environments that
you think that when you leave something
like the GOP on principle then everyone
respects you but in in
but in real life what it means is you
step out uh like uh off of a cliff and
then like there there's no new group
there to greet you you sound like you
have some experience in that and true
look we could also we could also title
this segment
um why Liz Cheney and Adam kinsinger
dear friends of ours will never be
speaker of the house or president of the
United States the reality is there just
is not a coalition for you and in some
ways it makes sense okay you leave the
Republican party you say the the hard
truths about your former colleagues and
now they don't want you they're you're
not welcome there anymore the Democrats
from my perspective leaving the
Republican Party the Democratic party
says oh we really like when Jolly you
know tells the truth about Republicans
but in their defense they already have a
coalition that represents their values
and so great Jolly says the right things
on climate and and democracy and LGBT
and guns but we're already there so it's
not like there's this huge reward like
the Democrats say oh we need Jolly to
come over and be a spokesperson
absolutely not they don't need kinsinger
and they don't need Cheney and they
don't need others so you do find
yourself in this no man's land where
though 40 percent of the country is as
you well know and speak to continues to
identify fi is politically independent
there is nothing that binds that 40
percent together there is no Coalition
where just all parties of one if you
will which then led me into the
independent space to try to figure out
how do you navigate this and how do we
create a platform for more people I
think you were the flag bearer for
independent politics uh essentially the
last several years uh and you so one big
learning was look trying to dictate
top-down beliefs is not a workable way
to build said Coalition particularly
when you're talking about independence
what are the other lessons or battle
scars from your time as in my mind
either the year one of the foremost
leaders for independent politics no no
you're very kind and you as well many
leaders and and we follow many others
look the True Battle Scars are that the
system's rigged the system's been built
for the two major parties right I mean
look Coke and pep he would be happy to
go to Federal Court to sue against the
New Market entrant because I have all
the power so it's not a surprise the
system's rigged in favor of the two
major parties to try to quash the
participation of Independence and minor
parties I would say though the the
philosophical Journey if there's one big
thing I mean this is this is really what
I wrestle with because I think
it could change how we talk about
politics
we do talk about how can you coalesce
minor parties or new parties and we
start with this idea as you mentioned of
a top-down belief everybody has to
believe in a certain thing well if you
start to break away from that you move
to the big tent approach which is how
can we get jolly and yang and Christy
Todd Whitman on the same platform that
that's a traditional big tip approach
that's great too but let's push that
further and the further is the one big
thing which is
Jolly's in favor of lower taxes but an
assault weapons ban Jolly's in favor of
Greater LGBT uh defense and and and
personal Liberty defenses but he's also
in favor of robust religious Liberties
how how can we speak to all of that and
honestly I think the Democratic party at
times tries to do that I mean I think
the Democratic party is slowly
recognizing there's opportunity there to
bring in a broader Coalition but that
one big thing is not that a big tent has
to include more than one person it's
that one person themselves needs a
bigger tint because where can Jolly
exercise my politics to lower taxes and
ban assault weapons that party does not
exist today the Democrats would say come
with us on guns Republicans would say
come with us on taxes but don't talk
about those other things we don't want
you to talk about those other things so
for me it's also why I didn't join
another party leaving the Republican
party it was that discovery that the
parties today Crush in independent
thought they crush it my experience on
the house floor routinely as a
republican member of Congress was that
if I wanted to speak out to to basic
ideas of where the country was on a lot
of these issues we've discussed I was
the outlier I was told to be quiet the
money would dry up I wasn't allowed to
do that but again as I mentioned there
wasn't a welcome Embrace from the
Democratic side because they didn't need
to in their defense and that's the big
thing people's own politics are left
right and middle if you really
self-examine where you are on issues
rarely are you so rigid that you're in
exactly the same spot on every single
issue we face ideologically so how do we
create that freedom of independent
thought how do we celebrate it and and
honestly how do we Elevate this idea of
pluralism that the country was founded
on
foreign
this program is sponsored by betterhelp
it's a holiday season which is a happy
and festive time for many but it's also
a challenging time for many and if you
get down to the dumps it's a great time
to get some help I first saw a therapist
when I was a teenager and have been a
big believer in therapy ever since and
as the world's largest therapy service
better help has already matched 3
million people and Counting with
professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
and if things aren't clicking you can
easily switch to a new therapist anytime
it couldn't be simpler think about it
why would you necessarily need to go
into an office when you can get therapy
right from the comfort of your own home
in a way that's accessible private and
affordable it is therapy of the future
I'm really glad that we're sponsored by
Better Health you can learn more and
save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com Yang that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p Dot com slash yang
[Music]
that they made a number of moves
recently to adjust the presidential
nomination States or at least it's
looking like in the Democratic party so
um IO I spent a lot of time looks like
it's getting booted uh and it's going to
be replaced by South Carolina at the
head of the line coincidentally the
reason why Joe Biden became president
yeah I'm sure it's a total coincidence
Andrew you're on it people say what does
this mean for other candidates Joe
Biden's no fool he he knows if he's got
somebody biting in his ankles in a
primary he'll walk away in South
Carolina pretty happy
yeah
um so this is more or less the Joe Biden
calendar
um but but one of the things that I I
find uh uncomfortable is that yeah you
have the polarization of the parties and
what got me here was realizing that the
polarization is just going to get worse
uh where almost half of Democrats regard
Republicans as corrupt and a threat to
the country and about the same
percentage Republicans feel that way
about Democrats percentages are going up
uh and you and I remember when your home
state of Florida was a swing state it
might not be any more uh Iowa was a
swing state that Obama won Ohio was the
quintessential swing state Missouri was
a quintessential swing state uh and now
uh the Democrats are essentially pulling
up Stakes out of Iowa so you can kiss
Iowa goodbye for the Democrats
essentially forever as far as I can tell
um I mean it was plus nine Trump I
believe in the the last uh Democratic
House member Cindy axney just lost her
race and so you see this identification
of the parties uh kind of skewing where
before you know they were talking to the
same States at least in the early uh
contests but but now and the the despair
I have is that the Democrats look up and
say uh well Iowa Ohio Missouri shrug uh
your two Midwestern not diverse enough
so we're going to trade you in for
Nevada Arizona and Georgia who it was
like more our speed uh and and it just
accelerates these uh different uh tribal
identities that are having different
conversations
yeah so let's talk about tribalism
culturally because I I think we're
entering a new era frankly in our our
culture and I want to I want to
investigate that a little bit I would
say on the primaries let's see what
happens I I do think the Democratic
party in moving to South Carolina
arguably gravitated more towards what
their Coalition currently looks like
right and I think that's your point like
they moved to their home playing field
as opposed to trying to appeal to some
of the States they're losing right the
flyover states white Agriculture and so
forth I think what Democrats would say
is South Carolina has a proper
representation of communities of color
that we didn't achieve in earlier States
we have an agrarian economy we have
white working class there's there's more
diversity that that represents who we
are as a party but you are stepping away
from voters then that you don't
currently have which is which is the yin
and the Yang of it I would suggest
Republicans are making a huge tactical
error and have been for a decade in
continuing to consolidate their base of
of white Christian America and ignore a
lot of attempt at diversity Donald Trump
actually tried more than anybody else
you just did so in a highly offensive
way that nobody could really celebrate
but but let's let's talk a little bit
about tribalism because I'm fascinated I
I have a theory now I'm not an academic
so I'm going to posit a theory that may
or may not work and hope in academic at
some point in the next decade runs with
it some academics listen to this so go
ahead that's right I actually think
we've entered
call it the post information age for as
a stakeholder term
and the reason it's important is I think
the information age between mass media
social media everything else we have has
achieved
breaking down the geographic communities
that have held us together right you
used to know your neighbors know who
your neighbors were we got up in the
morning we read one local newspaper
which forget about their bent this isn't
left or right we also most local
newspapers were Centrist but continue
yeah but we started with the same
narrative every day we lived in the same
ecosystem and there was a bond to that a
stickiness to that there were six or
eight churches there were six or eight
Civic clubs there were six or eight
schools what the information delivered
to us is the ability to now ignore those
communities in some places the pillars
have been broken down and your community
now is all over the world and your
community is the community that shares
your view of the world your tribe right
so now you wake up and if you're a Mark
Levin junkie you're more in line with
the Mark Levin junkie five states away
and you're communicating with them and
in doing so you're creating you know a
hurdle between you and your actual
Community participants your physical
Community participants why does that
matter
well it matters because we now don't
have the relationships that held us
together and our relationships actually
represent the divisions we have as
opposed to what we shared in common
I think this is real like we feel it
right we feel it but I actually think we
need to begin to study what does this
mean for how we all share this wonderful
country and what does it mean for how we
share a democracy because now we
immediately have pitted against each
other based on our allegiances not based
on our communities and the tribalism
piece I don't know how we saw I really
don't we almost have to ask for people
to respond to their better Angels but
the challenge just can be too hard on a
day-to-day basis to do that
foreign
stuff to wear that makes me feel super
heroic nowadays is my forward hoodie the
forward cap forward t-shirt so we get
new arrivals all the time if you want to
do something fun start conversation
support forwards work go to
shop.forwardparty.com and check out the
swag pins cups thermoses is that the
same thing no it's not suitcases TV sets
we actually don't sell either of those
go to shop.forwardparty.com for the
funnest ways to support forward
[Music]
you talk about how the system is now
rigged for the two parties uh and there
was just a dump on Twitter about how
both the major parties were in touch
with various administrators to uh get
various people and messages blocked on a
scale that most people did not realize
was happening yeah um so you and I are
trying to do something fascinating which
is create more options and Alternatives
in a system uh that is trying to tries
to prevent that so what do you see as
the biggest opportunities I I feel like
you and I are operators and tacticians
and you look around and you scratch your
chin and you're like hmm like okay you
built the system the system's supposed
to make it very hard for people like us
so what are the opportunities and that
there's uh Sometimes some really unfair
retaliation where you talked about how
serve America movement got on the ballot
in the state of New York which was very
very difficult and then Governor Cuomo
just wiped uh wiped it out with a stroke
of a pen and there was no popular uproar
yeah it was just like and I don't like
the fact that you guys now have party
access and and just arbitrarily raise
the threshold I mean that was bananas
yeah yeah so in the state of New York I
believe at the time there were eight
parties Cynthia Nixon everybody knows
are outside of New York from Sex and the
City remember she challenged Cuomo and
was a thorn in his side she did so on a
minor party line so when she loses Cuomo
says you know what I'm just going to
eliminate the bottom four political
parties in the state of New York and
poof if you were registered with the
serve America movement or one of those
other parties you got a letter from the
state saying hey it doesn't exist
anymore not because the serve America
movement went away but because Cuomo
said I don't want people to participate
in in those minor parties so look that
is uh in some ways graft if you will as
opposed to structural you know needing
structural reform I would say what are
the two opportunities electoral reform
you're one of the best
evangelists for that what we saw in
Alaska moving to the top four and then
ranked Choice voting where on Election
Day they elect a Statewide Republican
senator and a Statewide Democratic
member of Congress because they can
think rationally and they can vote by
consensus we're seeing the Electoral
Reform movement grow a lot of the
hurdles are the incumbent parties don't
want it so a lot of States they say no
no voters you're not you're not allowed
to have this Authority we're going to
keep this Authority as legislators but
electoral reform structurally without
question and then two something you know
well you know the media ecosystem would
benefit from investment in a much more
robust independent space and there's a
supply and demand question here we we
Chase affirmation where we can find it
and so right now we have a lot of major
media platforms whose viewership is
pretty well defined
but there is not that singular place
that town square that that platform for
people who are really independent or who
are Big Ten or like myself whose
politics are left right and middle that
doesn't exist and and it will take a
significant investment from an
entrepreneur or a philanthropist to say
I'm going to commit to three to five
years to make this happen but I think
the audience is there and and we see
little Snippets of it right what
Smerconish has done what Cuomo arguably
is trying to do in news nation is trying
to do we'll see if it's successful but
you have people testing that independent
unaffiliated audience that platform
doesn't exist but all of these things
from structural reform to Media frankly
to the formation of new minor parties is
about coalescing this 40 percent of the
country that continues to say I can't
see myself in either partisan bucket the
governor of Connecticut recently came
out for ranked Choice voting uh and that
was the result of the gubernatorial run
you discussed earlier that I think you
had a hand in
um you actually were standing there
grinning like a Cheshire Cat at the
governor's announcement because you were
like well I knew how much work this took
tell everyone how the heck
uh that endorsement of RCV came to pass
in Connecticut uh and then we can talk a
little bit about the next steps because
the governor endorsing it doesn't mean
it's a done deal yeah so look the the
independent reform space I say is kind
of three lanes you have the let's all
get a long Lane right our friends over
at No Labels that say ours and D should
work together you have the Electoral
reform Lane that says we want ranked
Choice voting open primaries
gerrymandering reform and then you have
the new party lane people who have
decided the only way to really
effectuate change to get people to do
something is to create a party that can
compete with them and so in that third
lane where the serve America movement
started to operate we ran a Unity ticket
as I mentioned for Connecticut governor
and lieutenant governor in a lot of
States including in Connecticut if you
achieve a certain vote threshold three
percent five percent whatever the number
is you receive a ballot line for the
next gubernatorial race meaning you get
to automatically nominate somebody to be
on the ballot well in some states they
also have what's called Fusion voting
where you can nominate multiple parties
can nominate the same person New York
does this for instance the Working
Families party and the Democratic party
nominates typically Chuck Schumer and
AOC and it allows the minor party to
have a little bit of influence so in
Connecticut they had both we got we
achieved minor party status to get the
ballot line and they have Fusion voting
now this is where a lot of people say
well aren't minor party spoilers or why
do you even care about three to five
percent because you can change the world
with it and we knew that yep and so we
got a ballot line for the 22 this this
past November's gubernatorial race and
we had the opportunity to nominate
whomever we wanted we could have
nominated the guy down the street or we
could have nominated either the major
party candidates the Connecticut state
committee for the serve America movement
which operates under a couple different
names under state law actually in
interviewed the governor and the
Republican nominee and some of the
others and said look our big goal is not
necessarily to win the 22 election
realistically that's probably out of Out
Of Reach but what we would like to do is
ask for you to help voters be empowered
with ranked Choice voting and in that
case the incentives lined up for the
incumbent Governor to say
if I endorse ranked Choice voting and I
promise to try to get it through the
legislator can I have your third party
line so that I can give voters multiple
ways to vote for me and so the serve
America movement did and ultimately we
had that press conference which you're
describing where this minor party
announced the nomination of the sitting
governor and in turn the sitting
Governor announced that he would support
help get ranked Choice voting through
the legislature so how how can you help
the Connecticut legislature has to pass
the bill the governor has to introduce
the bill the legislature has to pass it
and get it signed into law and honestly
the momentum is there for electoral
reform so if you're in Connecticut or
have Connecticut ties lean in on this
one and try to insist that the governor
and the legislature passes ranked Choice
voting
foreign
you know what we all do and we want to
do more of sleep but one way we can feel
like we slept more is actually improve
the mattress that you're sleeping on
I've been a mattress guy since my 20s
when it seemed impossible to afford a
decent mattress and right now the
mattress I'm sleeping on yes it's true
is a helix sleep premium mattress the
Helix lineup includes 14 unique
mattresses and you can figure out which
one is best for you via a personalized
quiz why sleep on a one-size-fits-all
mattress when you can get one that's
customized for you and have it a hundred
nights risk-free that's how confident
they are that you're going to love this
mattress that's made for you via the
Helix sleep quiz don't take my word for
it it's also the number one mattress
pick by GQ wired chiropractors everyone
that knows mattresses loves this thing
including my kids Helix is offering up
to 200 off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com sharing with Helix better
sleep starts now
[Music]
the name of the org officially is
Connecticut voters first so everyone
Google that if you're in Connecticut or
friends in Connecticut but the governor
is going to talk about ranked Choice
voting in his State of the State address
in January and then there should be a
bill on the docket by February so we're
going to try and get a lot of people
signed up in January of next year but I
want people to think about what this
took where uh you know what politicians
respond to politics uh you know you had
you had two folks from each major party
running for governor their consultant
said hey whoever gets this line probably
gets three percent as uh an edge
um taking into account that this third
party
ticket got four percent in the previous
cycle so the consultant said this this
Line's worth three percent
um so being rational politicians both
the Democrat and Republican wound up
endorsing ranked Choice voting there are
some people who look at the Independent
party space and say oh oh don't do that
don't do that like reform but don't have
the Independent party and it's like well
the Independent party was necessary to
force the reform by getting that ballot
line that got the three percent
incentive for folks so David I'm so
inspired by what you all accomplished in
Connecticut I want to do the same thing
Nationwide so check it out here's how we
do it nationwide the 2020 presidential
race was decided by about 70 000 voters
in four states uh and they're going to
be about six swing States in 2024 we
know what they are it's Arizona Nevada
Wisconsin Georgia are the four core
swing States and then you could throw in
Michigan and Pennsylvania
um though those were a little bit uh
more of a spread so let's go get four
percent of the voters the independent
swing voters in those six swing States
just to raise their hands and say hey we
will support whichever major Party
candidate supports non-partisan
primaries and ranked Choice voting and
gets out of the way of the ballot
initiatives it'll probably be on the
ballot in 2024 in Nevada and maybe
Arizona and a couple of other states I
love it I love it absolutely it's a
perfect place to put the energy of the
independent movement and and you touched
on a couple themes there first is the
incentive structure you know I actually
I think tone is important in the
independent movement you have a lot of
people who are just angry and they're
always going to be angry and they're
going to beat up on the on the parties I
don't know that that helps us a lot
because the reality is
candidates today and incumbents are
responding to the incentive structure
that lets them keep their job and we all
do that in every Walk of Life if if
you're a street sweeper or a doctor you
do the things that let you keep your job
and get ahead and so we can beat up
incumbent Republicans and democrats for
their behavior but it's not going to
change anything because they're acting
rationally within the system if we can
change the system we will change their
behavior you articulate this perfectly
well Andrew when you're out across the
country if we change the incentives we
change their behavior and and that's
where the independent space is
contributing so much to the politics of
the country it the independent space
likes to get kicked around and oh these
rabble rousers are doing bad things no
no look if the independent space changes
the incentive structure in the country
then one of the two major parties is
going to realize wait a minute if we
broaden our tent if we reach for more
consensus and we can get rewarded for it
I've said this to my Democratic friends
you would have a governing Coalition for
the next three decades you would be a 60
party not a 51 or 52 percent party and
within the independent space there are
reasons to say we need a multi-party
democracy it is all over the world we
are the outlier and not having it all of
the metrics all the studies say
multi-party democracy is more effective
but in the screwed up way we do politics
in America if the contribution of
multi-party Advocates is to actually
create a bigger tent within one of the
major parties that says wait we want to
represent more and more of America
that's a heck of a contribution and
something to be proud of yeah the truth
is even if you had uh ranked Choice
voting and nonpartisan primaries the
winner is going to be a Democrat or
Republican most of the time uh you know
I mean because they still have a baked
in set of resources and people with
party identification you would have some
folks emerge every so often but the
incentives would be better for the
people in power I mean like in my own
way
yeah she's the perfect case study of of
what you get I I just want things to
work better for the American people
um and and I'm convinced that the
incentives you're talking about are the
path
um even if it means that the two major
parties are just doing a better job and
that's not necessarily like I like I do
think having new party entrance is going
to help spur uh like better policy and
more genuine
a genuine engagement with how people and
families are doing uh so David the thing
that upsets me the most is that
for each major party now the incentives
are just to try and eke out the next
election I mean I talk a little bit
about how if you're a Democrats it's
like well I now I don't have to care
about Iowa Ohio Missouri anymore because
you read and uh you know I mean I've
spent time in each of those States and
guess what they're still human beings
there and you know like Democrats and
Republicans alike that's right you know
it's like maybe you should still care
yeah
um uh and the quality of life in this
country has been uh degrading and
eroding in various ways uh in every
community in different ways I mean we're
31st in the world now in various core
measurements
um but like neither party needs to
really really uh focus on that because
you're like well you know and and this
is what you were talking about before
with the tribalism and the the
deterioration of local media and Civic
uh engagement there was a quote from
Michael Grunwald that scared the [ __ ]
out of me but I think it was probably
right it's a political journalist he
said there's a theory that we're now in
uh an era where the appearance of
governing is more important than actual
governing yeah um
because the media Echo Chambers are so
strong that it it's more about how
you're making people feel uh than about
policy and uh and I was like oh my God
that's frightening
um but but some of the numbers I've seen
actually indicate that we might be there
my great goal is to try and pull us back
for that and have people actually have
to be accountable to the facts on the
ground because one of the things that
stunned me since I started traveling the
country in 2011
um was how
negative a lot of the country feels uh
you know like that this is uh it you
know it like that there's like uh this
real sense of uh struggle uh nearing
desperation in a lot of places yeah yeah
Andrew Look consider in the State of
Florida my my home state people say oh
it's now a red State no it's not 45 to
48 of the state wants to go in a
different direction so it's not a red
State you can make the case that Alabama
slightly might be more of a red State
because it's 70 30. but the politics are
split but the system is set up where
it's a winner take all system and so the
minor minor party voters or minor
interest voters don't have to be
represented and and I would look I'm a
preacher's kid and so maybe I'm not well
suited for politics though I say that I
learned by watching the politics of the
church which can be far more vicious but
in terms of how I tried to serve it
didn't align with today's structure and
I'm going to share this with you because
I think it's critical for how how
leaders approach representative
democracy
in my very first race there was a
Libertarian in the race
I won 49
47-4 whatever than the numbers were
and that night after this hard-fought
race and in my remarks I said look I I
recognize tonight that more people in
this community asked to be represented
by somebody other than me
I only got 49 of up I said my job is to
prove to everybody that I can be trusted
with your voice
and then in some really personal ways I
you know for me the first time I was
ever elected was to Congress it was this
awesome case of first impression this
awesome honor that I felt and I and you
were you were one for one like you never
lost an election I never lost I didn't
lose I got redistricted two or three
times I never lost until the final race
I got redistricted six races later but I
I will tell you
I I asked myself a question and I think
it's important that you can actually go
to the Federalist Papers there's some
contemplation of this
it was my job as a member of Congress to
give voice to the entire Community or to
only those voters who voted for me
and
and I would suggest that the vast
majority of elected officials today
think it's the latter that if they just
give voice to the people that voted for
them they will repeat the formula for
their re-election and they're they're
fine
especially given our party primary
system yeah I think it's a higher
calling than that and so I was willing
to test that theory and and here's the
cool thing the the my district was 50
50. the district I represented was 50
50. Obama had won it and a republican
had won it I set out to try to give
voice to everybody
my first race I won with 49 of the of
the vote the next race I won was 70 of
the vote there's a reward for it now I
was undergoing all these redistrictings
and ultimately it came back to bite me
in a presidential year because I had
ticked off Republicans and Democrats had
their person as I mentioned but I do
think there's a reward in politics for
giving voice even to those who didn't
vote for you and ultimately what's
behind structural reform and electoral
reform and all these things we're
talking about is to try to reward people
that actually give voice to their
community and not just their party if we
can get there
then we'll accept the outcomes of
Elections we'll accept the outcomes of
policy making we won't see people try to
topple the government because they
didn't get their way and they feel
cheated because now we will have
restored trust between those who are
elected to serve and the voters who
elect them
David Rubinstein the founder of Carlisle
group was on the podcast a number of
months ago and he said that he talks to
members of Congress all the time and he
said that that when he talks to members
of Congress they are very very focused
on trying to keep their job they're
really scared of losing their job but
then after they lose their job they're a
lot happier he said he sees it all the
time yeah
um
uh so you're you're friends now with any
number of uh former members uh some of
whom are former members
um because they did the right thing sort
of like you did where you stood up to
the party and then you know got attacked
and the rest of it and then have now
gone down this other Road what do you
think about David's comments I agree
with it but I have very little patience
because of what we just talked about I
think when you're elected to serve you
should feel the calling to do what's
right my wife and I called it the sleep
well at night test and here's an example
I'll give you
I went into Congress there are a lot of
issues I I changed my mind on in
Congress when I felt the responsibility
to give voice to to consensus there were
some issues I changed my Minds on
um guns was one where I very
aggressively moved to the left the other
was campaign Finance I would have said
at the beginning of my career money a
speech and should be unregulated I now
think we should eliminate money from
politics use Public Finance and get
commercials off the air I think it's not
only corrupt but honestly I'll tell you
right now every member of Congress
spends more time raising money than than
doing their job and so what what I
introduced in Congress was called the
stop act it landed me on 60 Minutes they
did a bunch of secret cameras in the
nrcc which you can imagine what that did
for my reputation but but I gave a
speech about it and it was very simple
the stop act said no member of Congress
can ask anybody for money that's it
listen if here are the two caveats and
right now it's like 60 of the waking
hours but that's right and that was my
point my point was put down the phone
and get back to work so if you were if
you're not in office if you're a
Challenger
whatever the opportunity cost is to your
family or your job that's fine there's
no public cost to that that's a decision
you make once you're elected there's a
public cost to spending all your time
raising money and so that was a most
important thing secondly your campaign
can still go raise money right you can
have a campaign manager and a fundraiser
and all those people that get paid to do
that part of the job but as a member of
Congress my my bill is two pages said
you're not allowed to ask anybody for
money
so
I I got maybe five or six people to
co-sponsor the bill with me and I
acknowledge acknowledge at the time it
will take a scandal for this bill to
actually get the light of day 16. those
are five or six cool people like uh you
know was that a cross party lines or
they just yeah yeah we got Republicans
and Democrats now I had a lot of people
come up to me and say hey I wish I could
do this but you know I can't you know so
forth but here was the here's to your
point Steve Israel who is a friend of
mine a New York Congressman at the time
uh also the director of the Democrats
campaign arm spent a bunch of money
trying to beat me he was interviewed on
60 Minutes and said ah Jolly's idea will
never work it's a joke he's just playing
theater
I went to the house floor and I gave the
speech about the stop act and I begged
my colleagues I said please you all know
this is true and do something about it
while you have the power while you're in
office until you get out of office and
admit to the truth and then lament that
you didn't do anything about it
it's the incentive structure right and
and at some point
the conversations around structural
reform have to move
to whether and how we get to judge
elected officials because at some point
our elected officials are not honoring
the greater good they're not actually
solving the problems for us they're
protecting their own career we get to
judge that however we choose to we can
do it with our voice or we can do it
with our vote but regardless of any
structural reform we need an informed
electorate that says enough is enough
we've got to stop the current behaviors
of our incumbent elected members of
Congress amen uh so David you and I have
done our share of stumping around the
country for forward I I really enjoy
being your wingman uh and anytime the we
get to share a stage most people would
say that this is maybe one of the most
exciting times they've seen in a
generation
for independent politics you've been at
this for a number of years uh what are
you excited about moving forward and
then also what lies ahead for you how
can people follow you support you
because uh you know I think people
watching and listening to this be like
oh [ __ ] like you know if we had more
people like David in positions of of
power we we might be in a lot better
shape well Andrew you as well listen I I
mean all I knew of Andrew Yang was the
brand and the presidential candidate
when I first called you and said hey
let's try to make this work alongside of
a bunch of other uh good intended people
it's been a pleasure for me to get to
know you
um I here's here's why I think it's so
exciting
and and so here's the important
corporate disclaimer we always use I'm
not formally affiliated with forward but
I am a champion of the independent and
minor party space and I'm excited about
what forward is doing because what we
are seeing at forward is this catalyzing
of the movement that you rarely get to
see and so here's the a little bit of
inside ball game
for the success that is happening and I
think it's critical and frankly all the
pundits are missing this when it comes
to forward in the minor party space the
success
is in the organizing at the state level
where hundreds and thousands of people
are signing up and saying in my state I
want to do the things under state law
that allow us to achieve ballot access
that allow us to achieve party
recognition that allow us to run
candidates for County Commission and dog
catcher and Congress and the interesting
thing is all of that happens without the
notice of the pundits or the newspapers
because that's where the success of the
movement happens and and what you've
done it Forward is you've created a
platform now where people across the
country can go to a forward party or a
forward chapter in their state get
involved and create the success at the
national level when you think of
national parties they really only exist
for a few limited reasons one is brand
right you have to build and communicate
a brand in 2022 so what is that brand at
forward it's a bottom-up state-focused
coalition of 50 state parties that want
to create a multi-party democracy and
celebrate independent thought that's an
incredible value proposition so National
exists to maintain and grow the brand
and then to provide critical resources
legal resources political Consulting
resources evaluation of where races
might make sense and not this structure
is really at the state level the the
brand sits at the national level and
while all the pundits focus on the brand
and say well what's going on with the
brand they're missing what's happening
across the country you live it every day
this movement is alive and and at
forward you have the people smart enough
to take on the the rig system and say
we're going to create successes in these
dozen places and then people are going
to wake up and say wait I just missed
this story and now it's changed American
politics potentially forever yeah and
everyone watching and listening can be
part of this story in your state
beautiful wordparty.com just click on
your state you'll meet some awesome
people who are doing the real work uh
you know like a lot of people will look
at something and then turn away others
will roll up their sleeves and get their
hands dirty and Ford is filled with the
ladder you know like that's how great
things are built and oh by the way the
country needs it and our political
system uh desperately desperately needs
a body of motivated citizens to to build
this alternative that's exactly right
and as you've mentioned before I know
what 500 000 elected offices in the
country and 60 or 70 percent of them go
uncontested with only one candidate if
you're if you're listening to this today
think about in your community how many
local elected offices there are many
that go uncontested that is an
opportunity to grow a party like forward
a minor party Coalition is in those
races where the old Axiom there's not a
Republican or Democratic way to fix a
pothole that's true but in today's day
and age the Republicans and Democrats
are going to fight over that pothole and
at forward it's a republican pothole or
a Democrat a pothole at this point David
it's true maybe we can pull it back
maybe you could become a forward pothole
um so so how do people follow you and
keep up with you and uh and be excited
about your work uh look externally I
kind of I I live my life in part on
MSNBC and and Twitter on at David Jolly
FL look at this point I have a
comfortable so I feel comfortable in the
space of nonpartisan politics objective
analysis and look as a former Republican
who does believe that the party is
deeply flawed you will hear me
delivering commentary incredibly
critical of my former party and I think
it's important and and here's here's
what I would say Andrew you you know
this as well it's an Incredible Gift or
not gift it's a gift to the person to
have a platform to express your opinion
I'm grateful every day that I get to
participate by offering a voice but I
would also say it's not always easy to
level that criticism but I think there
are certain moments where there you have
to if if we truly are going to fix the
problems right Andrew Yang it's not easy
for you to say my experience in the
Democratic party led me to the
conviction that we have to create an
independent space David Jolly yes okay
he gets to go on on TV and talk about
the Republican Direction that's not
always just a reward it also comes at a
cost and so I think what people will
discover in this independent movement
right now is a lot of people of deep
conviction and yeah consider the good
people are doing this for the right
reasons man there's no other reason to
do it yeah consider the Good Will and
good spirit with which people arrive in
the independent space and so
um I look I appreciate the opportunity
to to participate in dialogue nationally
on TV sometimes on Twitter we'll we'll
see the direction that's going I don't
know I've tried to quit politics three
times Andrew and it's never quite worked
so I think I'm going to stick around for
a while that's really funny you should
have resigned yourself to it you know
the fact that you're a preacher's kid I
ran into another preacher's kid uh uh
the other night here in New York City
Chris Rock
um and I just thought when you said you
were a preacher's kid I was like wow
like preachers kids have some magic
powers you definitely have a lot of
patriotism and magic in you my friend uh
David looking forward to heading down
this road with you great to be with you
Andrew thank you for what you're doing
[Music]
foreign